[Applaudissements]
c'est le maire chez les mères la mère de
jean michel elle mettait toujours devant
la porte tout doit disparaître à niamey
des promotions toute l'année
oui les usa mais le problème de
l'algérie on a des problèmes
fondamentaux c'est qu'en fait il est
véritablement coincé du cul des quais
des missions pour prendre un peu de
séduction d'amour il ya un peu de sexe
ait tout de suite il se drape dans une
séance très et l'amour un peu aimé les
moins chères jir il est bien chez avant
le coeur très très tendre et la tob très
très dur
[Applaudissements]
x
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez la faire de chez vous elle va
démarrer de lava elle fait comme ça va
faire une ola qui passera gardien qui
permet de rabat et rappelez vous de
cette phrase que je ne peux pas dire
parce qu'elle a un petit peu je ne peux
pas la dire
mais elle restera dans les annales de
l'émission zonal oui c'est vrai
attention aux lancers partie
[Applaudissements]
alors elle a là et vous à tous j'ai
attendu la funci kiffa très bien mais le
coeur le coeur temps réel est le coeur
tendre et la top durchon tir de l'accord
à toi mais pourquoi tu as fait le choix
inverse alors dit explique nouveau sport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]